こんばんはこちらせていく花粉ですね
英語の勉強言葉の勉強どうやってそれ効果的にできるかと
日本ではもうもう沢山の人が英語を勉強してますよねー
またまあ中国語や韓国某スペイン語その他の言葉を勉強している人もいると思います
言葉の命私は猫このじゃなくて今もう
11 no 言葉ができるわけですよいま着5
勉強中なんですけれども
その効果的にですね
言葉を勉強するためにですね
非常に大事なことはそれが楽しく勉強しないといけない
楽しくない土地柄ないし楽しくないとですね
頭脳がなかなか覚えないですよね
それが一番大切な原則だと思います
大部分の人が楽しくない形で勉強しています
楽しいというのはまあその自分がやりたいような形で
だからまあもちろんも広い
そのな自分が興味を感じているもののまぁ
そういうものを聞いたり読んだりそれでもそれぞれの一つなんですけれどもそれもそり
3よりはですね
大事なことはですねー
あのあまり頃をしない形で勉強すればいいですがこのメガネがちょっと来
このメガネのほうがいいですよね
あの苦労しない形で勉強すれば一番効果的です
我々がねみんなね苦労しないと勉強しないと
なんか思ってるわけどっか痛くないと進歩しないと思っている人が多いと思います
それは逆なんですよ我々はもっとね
まあ中国の庶民の哲学というとその道
道ですよね
えその
ドアんザそう姫ですかだからも力あまり入れない方がいいです
力入れて勉強しようと思うようなものはですねそう忘れます
いくら苦労してもですねー
何日間でわすれますだそんな苦労しないほうがですねー
いいわけですよ忘れてもいいからだからあまり苦労しない形で勉強する場ですね
覚えであればまあ楽しいわけですよはされても構いません
そんなに苦労しなかったためですよだ一つのまあいい靴がの例があります
例えば本を読んでる時にえ
その
知らない多分を多いならば
あの
コンピュータで読んだ方もいいですというのはオンラインの事情がありますから
すぐその意味が出てきます
で
しかしもちろんこのコンピュータの前で読むよりも
どっかその座ってですね普通の本読んだ方が楽しいわけですけれどその場合は知らない
単語が出たらね
いいわけですよおいておいていいです
平部なくてもいいです私はだいたい辞書を使う時にすぐあの
わすれますからだから調べない
調べなくてもいいですその自然的にどんどんどんどん
何
声が増えてきますもし我々が続けて読みましたね
だからそれはだだからそんなね苦労したような
もう11
調べたりするようなことはあのやらないほうがいいですね
分布もそうなんですよ
僕の説明がはわからなくてもいいです
分布の説明とかいろんな表は見ても1いいですよ時々それがまあ少しずつ少しずつ
助かるんですけれども
大したすぐ佐野
文法の説明の選んでからね
ルールを見てからじゃあすぐ正しく話できるということはまずないわけですよ
そのルールもはしてれますしウールわかっててもよくわからないし
どうやってそれを実際に話する時に使えるかわからないし
だからそういうルールを読むのはですねこれは非常に間接的な影響しかないです
我々の頭脳がそんなその
lonely はねあまりあのすぐわからないんですよ
それよりもまあとにかくたくさん聞いたり読んだりすることによって
ずローが少しずつ少しずつ慣れてくるだからその分ぽのるーるー
時々見てはいいですよいってもいいんですけれどもそれをあのような非常に覚えようと
するような苦労は絶対ダメなんですよ
絶対ランス
もう一つはですねあの
普通のその言葉のその本にはですね色んな質問がある
これは何かまあ英語でユーモール the way to do my とその他の
こその単語ですね正しくた歌
使うために色んな層質問があるそれに応えないといけない
私はそんな質問は一切しません
一切しませんそれは嫌だから嫌なことは僕は嫌なことは嫌薄
やらないんですだから処理よりもええええたて今
チェックの本ですけども
その返事の方だけを見ますよねだからもしその
質問だね練習がですねええ
どこそこのですね文房の中問題に集中してですね
質問作るわけ出すわけでしょ
だからそれの返事を見ればそのパターンをたくさん
その集中した形で見ればそれが
頭脳に非常に影響なんですよ
それが効果的ただ考えて考えてどっちからカーって考えてサビ持っどれも意味ないん
ですよ
それそれ行っても良くならないです
だからイージーな方がいいですあるいはあの
立てればですねなんか
選んであるいは聞いた後ですねその間プレイ編春ファッションが分かりましたかてなぜ
その a さんが b さんに
その
を挙げたこと笹一切僕はそんなことはもう返事しないです私の効いたあるいは選んだ
怪異解釈はですねそれ間違ってもいいわけですよ
間違ってもいいです分からない部分がたくさんあったけれども構いません
それは読んだことだけでいいです聞いたこ
とだけでいいですそれだけがですね頭脳にそれが豊富な
その言葉に対する経験になりますからそれは変わらなくても構いません
構いませんあるいはそのフラッシュカーズがあるでしょ
ファーし cars うちのリンクシステムでもフラッシュカードがあるんですよ
だけどもそれはもちろんコンピューターない ci 4
んでつかオファーしかあるんですけども私がねフランシーカーズの
表面にですねー
もう
さあ
看護まあ今着帽ですけどもチェック5号の単語英語の説明
そしてリンクの場合はこのフレーズが入ってきますけども前穂一面目に出てくる
だが浦和は3歳見ないんですよ表だけ
便びんびんびんびん表だけの暮らしカー所できるだけ早く
見る2
いうだけですあまり頭を使ってもですねいないです
あまり頭を使いますとね距離短期的目無理にして入らないんですよ
無意味ですそんな苦労しても効果はないんです
そうですよねあの辞書でもですねオンライン辞書僕は普通の子所北絶対使いません
そりゃ無駄ですすぐ忘れますからだけでもオンラインのですね
在線ですか a 辞書はね必ず
私は英語
ある人はねああこれは英語をやるなら英語英語の辞書を使った方い
これ上たんじゃないもうそれがやはり自分の母国語
日本の日本語ですぐやはりこの意味の説明を見た方が早いです
ただこの日本語は100%良い子あるこの映画というわけじゃないんです
その定義とが説明見ても実際にこの言葉のみ意味
その範囲をわかるためにはですねたくさん読んでたくさん聞いてからでないとすぐ二種
の説明見ては見てでもだけではわからないですよね
だから
ゼンマイ全般的にですね他には何か
そうですねそれからまあ用水用はですね
あの楽しい形で抱く書いい子な形であまり
ん
無理に力使わない形で
勉強すれば楽しいつづく
いっ
嫌じゃないそれと効果的です
それのほうが効果的です
あの
いろんな the no なんですから同じグッズの言葉を何回もなんかも海底に
できるだけこれ覚えようとし無理
このこの言葉が覚える時間があるそれが今か2週間豪華版と一号か
それは自分がコントロールできないですそれは頭脳が自分で買っていけますから
だからあまり無理に力入れない方がいいです
楽しく作って時間たくさんそれが大事
聞いたり読んだりいろんな形でですね
その言葉と付き合うのは第二月あのだから時間が大事
楽しく
そしてあんまり無理に苦労しない形で勉強したほうがもう全然
一番効果的ですそれは私が11過去今12カ国合名を勉強している
経験があるからそういうことは言えます
何かご質問あったらどうぞ聞いてください